so biotechnology has been in use since
1919 so it's a long time back
and uh it has uh its first application
was in dna recombination experiments
with bacteria right
and today biotechnology in itself has
been applied in manufacturing of
medicines
medicinal devices diagnostic tools bio
bio materials food technology and food
production
all of that but today we wanted to talk
to you about another exciting field
which is computational biology so
computational biology
which is a relatively new field of uh
research
has been evolving at an exponential
phase and
it's such an exciting field of biology
and
we will learn more about it in today's
session
uh and to talk a little bit about uh
computational biology there's a reason
that this
exponential pace that
it has got it is because of the enormous
amount enormous amount of
biological data that has accumulated
over the years
and the size of this data is ever
growing
and the application of biology in life
in itself
is growing uh already and it has been
shown
even for the experiment that uh some
scientists did
a few a few days a few months ago that
dna can be used to store
uh data just like our typical hard
drives right
scientists were able to show that 700
terabytes of
uh data could be stored in a single
you know single gram of dna so that's
like pretty exciting right
so but our objective here is to simplify
complex bioinformatics methods that have
been applied in these
amazing experiments and then uh
we won't also want to use these methods
effectively and efficiently to tackle
unsolved problems in biology and in
healthcare
so i would also like to tell you about
in much more detail about the omics
logic program
but before i do that i would like to ask
uh
if any one of you would like to have a
discussion a question please feel free
to put it in the chat
chat option so that we can go through
this later
and answer your questions so uh going
back to the presentation and about the
homicide programs and
what we've been doing and been talking
about so the goal of omics logic program
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and peer examples
another aspect of uh important aspect of
omics logic program is to develop a
growing community with a shared passion
for data driven research
and application of citizen scientist
science projects
so we have a growing community of over
10 000 people who are computational
biologists
researchers biologists clinicians
who interact with each other and enrich
this information
sharing and collaboration the third
objective is to enable students
and clinicians and faculty of all
background people who are interested
genuinely
would want to learn more about it apply
these skill sets
in their research areas in for job
opportunities
and to develop noble and independent
research using
uh life science or the latest uh
technologies
in in bioinformatics and computational
biology so these are some of the
objectives that we
that we wanted to tell you all about
and the next thing uh is about the
program itself because
we would want to you know complete some
of these objectives by going through a
training method
so this online program is designed for
everyone
including students who don't have a
background in bioinformatics
so the topics covered in this program uh
enables anyone to learn the ngs data
analysis
because we will be going through
different kind of processing sections
but for doing different sort of analysis
such as genomic analysis
and i've heard many of you are
interested in transcriptomic analysis
and interpreting the omics data using
machine learning techniques
so we will learn about also along with
this we will also be learning about
public repositories where various file
formats are being you know deposited
by different laboratories and companies
and their application
and then understanding their application
for biological research
so this analysis will include we will be
doing annotation
visualization and interpretation of the
results
so uh before we go into those technology
let me start today by mentioning that as
a company
in this space we are focused on
addressing
some of the pressing needs in
biotechnology
and in clinical market by providing user
friendly tools for researchers
clinicians students to leverage this
transformational opportunity of our
lifetimes
because this is where the uh where the
innovation is coming this is where the
latest technology is heading to us today
we will be learning about the overview
of topics as
uh as promised that will be covered in
the program so let's start discussing
about the basics of bioinformatics
big data and this concepts and
applications
so in in bioinformatics
if we talk about big data so the
biological experiments produce
magnitude of multitudes of data today so
compared to 20 years ago so before that
we were using single experiments to
generate data now there are
thousands of experiments automated
experiments that are generating this
multitude of data and then we have open
source data
databases like ncbi uh scientists from
different part of the world
can share their data and can collaborate
with ease
so that's the new world and we have now
crossed the
excel barrier as well so earlier we were
used to
use i mean most of the time we even use
excel
ms excel for uh for uh you know
collaborating and sharing data so
bioinformatics researchers
who are now are adapt with
statistics data and programming on top
of
domain knowledge there are also demands
such as you know
learning tools such as panda nymphy uh
matplot our shiny
all of that that actually efficiently
help us to you know
maybe use machine learning as well so
this
is uh right now is the market in
bioinformatics
there's a huge opportunity associated
with it or also because it's a growing
market
and uh it has a lot of demand
for all the biomedical research that is
ongoing
disease related research and many more
application that today we will discuss
so learning about this i mean what is
the gap
where we are i mean what is lacking and
what
we can do so breakthroughs in molecular
biology
advances of precision medicine
biotechnology and agriculture
have translated into advanced
technologies right
because now we are generating data with
ease
and that simplified generation of
accurate and in-depth data
is is something like a blessing in a way
but at the same time it poses like a lot
of
questions because there's a lack of
analytical
power and appropriate skills that
creates
like a huge gap because we have high
quality data now
but we need experts to understand the
data and make sense of that data
so those expertise and skill sets are
lacking
and many of uh because of this there's
this gap
between data and information in this in
this field of computational biology
and bioinformatics and from a standpoint
of what has been
seen as so bioinformaticians as such
were viewed more like you know computer
scientists before
who could manage a database maybe run
some algorithms but modern
bioinformaticians
are different and i'm tell you i'm going
to tell you why
because modern bioinformaticians have to
identify
what questions what questions a
researcher
should ask how to look for um
right answers that's a very important
part
and then how to what to do with this
large data
large amount of data produced from these
studies that is also a job of a
bioinformatician to learn and understand
and also for all those people who are in
a pa
who are in biology and are now
progressing towards
uh learning more about biology and its
application
so in bioinformatics uh
now um as i was telling you about the
opportunities
these scientists who are being able to
do all of this
who can ask the research question find
data set
understand what answer that data set can
give
these scientists are now integrated into
every research team
making them into the core of innovation
so it's very important
and these uh so biology
and as a field has been now ushering
with the age of ai
big data with it and creating a new line
of scientists that's where i'm coming at
which is bioinformaticians and
computational biologists
so now about uh bioinformatics
and the different kind of challenges
so when we talk about you know technical
demand that prevents us from learning
these skill sets
because of the computational power that
is sometimes required
for us to do all this analysis so in
most of the cases that
that means that you know our ability to
analyze data
and extract meaningful meaningful
information
is lagging behind because of the pace at
which the new
new data is being generated so
oftentimes like clinician
biologists students from life science
background report
about challenges with data analysis and
interpretation that is holding them back
and limiting their ability to rely on
advanced technologies such as genomes
genomic sequencing
which we could incorporate in our
studies in our research
and that could actually give us a really
bright clear picture of what what is
going on
so uh if i talk about bioinformatics and
computational biology the first three
words that
you know wikipedia used to describe
bioinformatics are
um is an it is an interdisciplinary
field
so when we talk think about these three
broad
fields for example biology statistics
computer science
or you can say instead of statistics
data science
but what exactly these disciplines uh
are
and are there other fields within this
these disciplines
so when it comes to application in the
context of biology
the current realm of molecular biology
in the current realm of biology includes
molecular biology
genetics genomics proteomics
metabolomics systematic
evolution evolution uh pharmacology
biomedicine
healthcare uh healthcare health sciences
and
and the list goes on so this is not an
exist exhaustive list but
when it comes to computer science there
are there are like obvious ones
like software engineering database
management
uh information uh information
engineering
natural language processing image
processing so these are
some of the fields that are associated
with the interdisciplinary
nature of uh bioinformatics or
computational biology
and how we can now being being able to
utilize
these different areas of uh you know
these different technologies
into one area of biology so so what is
bioinformatics i think it's a
convergence of biology and data
where both are equally important
so um we've been talking about data
so let's understand some of the data
types which are like some of the genetic
data types
omix data types so omix data includes
phenomics genomics
[Music]
epigenomics technologies and that can be
used to
these technologies are uh are so
important in today's world because they
can be used to explore the roles
relationships actions of various types
of molecules
that makes up our cell that makes up a
cell of an organism
so many of this omics data can be
generated using the ngs technology which
is
commonly also known as high throughput
sequencing
and this data shows as i was telling you
before this data shows detailed
information
about genomic variants pattern of gene
isoform expression and for an entire
organism
and for the entire uh time point so
the application of this technology these
technologies is something that is really
exciting
and that we will be learning about in
the next few in the next
few slides so one particularly
uh exciting area of bio bioinformatics
uh
is its use in precision and uh
personalized medicine i think many of
you have heard about it
so what what is happening is doctors are
learning more and more about the
influences of the gene on a person's
physiology
is a person's metabolism and more
importantly how
drugs interact with their exact
phenotypes
so these are some of the things other
than that using a patient's
personal genetic makeup and comparing it
with the database of thousands of other
patients
doctors can make more informed decisions
about treatment
and therapeutic choices so these are
some of the possibilities that are
already happening
in many places some of the drugs may be
more efficient for a patient than others
while some of the drugs may may have
more unwanted side effects uh
for some other patients all all these
could be
you know theoretically can be evaluated
now
given the hospital haven't i mean maybe
hospital
or the organization have an access to
those databases and then they have the
expertise
to compare and find uh similar genotypes
that could be treated with similar drugs
so there are
different uh applications in medical
sciences
that that could help make the entire
healthcare system or the medical science
more robust empirical and casual than
uh correlational and or uncertain
right so most of such data types are
generated randomly
at a high speed these sort of data sets
are
generated at a really high speed and
these require
like com complex computational data
processing system
a procedure to generate structured data
sets
which can be visualized and analyzed uh
statistically so that is some of the
challenges
that are associated with such high
throughput data
but i mean this is a program that where
we would want to simplify that
and take you through this entire process
of how we can
actually do this uh by
learning the logic
now um this about this training program
so in this first training program we
will have live sessions
uh fpv and uh the first live session
will be about orientation
and introduction to omix logic
coursework and access to the
multiomics user-friendly tiba info
platform
so after the program registration and
many of you might have already
registered
for the program the first week
we will have participants and we will
have orientation under introduction
section
a session in this session we will be
collaboratively working with students
to complete their academic profile on
learn omis logic
and set up accounts on big data
analytical t-band for platform
so uh about this i mean anyone
anyone can join the omixlogic
bioinformatics community
for free and and that will we will be
showing you in a while
uh so in this week we will also learn
about big data
application of bioinformatics and uh
after we do the sign up which we will be
doing in the next uh
next few slides i'll be taking you
through the hands-on
courses and the premium courses
associated with
each week for you to learn all of this
on your own
so in the next session after the first
orientation
session and the introduction session
where we get to learn
about you about your interest about the
area
that you would want to work on maybe if
not about the basic training
the help that you need to go to the next
level
so in the next session we will be
learning about this various
ngs technology and ngs technologies
starting with genomics we will learn to
we will learn to analyze uh ngs genomic
data
and to give you an overview genomics
isn't
is an essential essential sub subfield
of bioinformatics
and is a major force in expanding human
knowledge for genetically associated
associations with disease and other
traits it's an interdisciplinary field
again
and it includes development of methods
for dna sequencing
as well as big data analysis for genomic
sequences so
ngs data or ngs techniques allow
whole genome sequencing and then
analysis of epigenetic factors
for as epigenomics for dna protein
interaction
dna methylation with i mean it is very
efficient and which has very efficient
way to identify those and there are
massive databases obviously i talked
about
ncbi there's gene bank embl sra
for uh for you to do data driven
discovery and knowledge discovery
so this session uh serves an as an
introduction
to the field sub disciplinary field of
genomics
participants will get familiarized with
biology of genetics genetic variation
and other practical applications
and to tell you i mean i will be telling
you more about this
uh entire week uh once we go once you
all
uh are signed up so that we can have a
like a demonstration
of what will be covered so in the next
session after learning about genomics
we will learn about metagenomics or you
will have an opportunity to learn about
meta genomics so this is a one month
program
and i would want to clarify that we will
have you will have a
lot of resources that you can you know
complete in that period or you can
extend
uh keep on extending and keep on
learning
about different data types so yeah
obviously
there's an opportunity to do this right
now in a month's time but
i mean many of you would want to go and
deep dive
and keep can do uh these analysis
after subscribing for the program um
every month
so in this session we will learn about
application of microbiome metagenomic
analysis and life sciences
and uh as as you know metagenomics is to
study
a collection of genetic materials or
genomes from a mixed community of
organisms
metagenomics is usually refers to study
of microbial community
and we have also uh
different projects in metagenomics to
explain
different sort of analysis that i'll
take you through uh after the login
so in after the metagenomics section
uh we will move to another section of
analysis which is transcriptomics
analysis this is like high throughput
gene expression data analysis
so in this session we will be doing the
analysis
using omix logic resources and the tbi
info platform
that we will be talking to you about uh
very soon in the session
so transcriptomics to give you an
overview is is to study
uh organisms transcriptome the
transcriptome refers as a sum of an
organism organisms rna transcript
right so the dna information
that is there in the genome gets
converted into rna
through a process called transcription a
segment of dna that gets transcribed
into
uh into an rna molecule is called the
transcriptome
transcript unit so studying and
understanding the transcriptome
gene expression expression levels help
us understand
that what are the proteins or what are
the you know
key genes that were maybe expressed
differently in a
different condition so it is also about
comparing comparing
these uh different uh expression
profiles that we get from different
experiments
and uh that technology and will be
also covered like com doing differential
gene expression
how would you do that how can you get
from raw data to a structured table of
expression first of all
and uh identify which are the important
genes that have shown this variation by
using
different type of statistical analysis
so we will be learning
we will be learning and we will also
learn to use this various statistical
methods of data analysis using
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning
that can be applied to biomedical data
or different kind of other data types
so using various examples of omics data
we will see
how such analysis can yield significant
results
for various biomedical applications and
it's i quoted this because it's very
important because
when you are looking uh in for
information from a
very big data it's like finding needle
from the haystack
so significant uh result is something
that is uh very important and could be
you know if it is a research it could be
publishable as well
so about the omixlogic program
in this omixlogic beginners training
program
the participants will have an
opportunity to learn about various
technologies
tools algorithms and pipelines and
workflows and data sets and research
publications
and these are some of the six data types
that you can see on the slide
so together with this existing module
modules
for which you will gain access for the
omics logic learn portal
where you can explore these modules
exercise the pipeline building
how can you build a pipeline how can you
do uh coding from the very basic
and apply it for bioinformatics not
hardcore
programming and various methods of
analysis using project
uh examples from peer reviewed
peer-reviewed publication
but to start with this i mean we
will have to do